hey youtubers is Charlie so the Russos
came out and said that after Captain
America Civil War cap is not cap anymore
so this is gonna be breakdown of what's
going on it's a big easter egg for the
comic books most of you're just like
what the hell is going on
no more Captain America well one you
have to remember that this is
technically the third Captain America
movie remember what happened at the end
of the third Iron Man movie it was kind
of a bookend for his character he's like
Iron Man no more he rips the arc reactor
out of his chest and throws it in the
bay but come to Avengers age of Ultron
and look it's Tony Stark with the newly
christened Avengers tower that they've
been living in going on missions all
over the world so it's almost like the
end of the Iron Man trilogy was written
to exist out of continuity like kind of
has its own thing beyond what's going on
with the Avengers so a little bit of
that was happening with this third
Captain America film but originally it
wasn't Civil War it was like a
completely different zombies storyline
so when Robert Downey jr. got involved
they blew it up into Captain America
Civil War kind of like an Avengers movie
but still called a Captain America movie
they basically left it on a beach where
Steve Rogers is a logical extension of
the plot is disillusioned with the
government and just puts the shield down
and walks away
he becomes a fugitive goes to the raft
freezes team and then they just kind of
ride off into the sunset you're left to
wonder what they're gonna do you know
very clearly they're still gonna fight
crime they're going to do the things
that they normally would do but just
under the radar so it's kind of like a
version of Secret Avengers but cap left
his shield he might not be wearing the
uniform anymore so he's kind of left the
mantle for now that doesn't mean that
they'll never do another Captain America
film it just means that this is like the
next logical step for his character and
something really big is going to have to
happen to make him recommit to that so I
know there's been a lot of changes going
on behind the scenes at Marvel Studios
in the last year they've kind of gone
off as their own separate thing Kevin
Feige has a lot more control over them
now so a lot of people felt like but
before that happened the conditions that
the actors were working under weren't
ideal weren't as good as they could be
so now that it looks like they've sorted
that all out the Avengers that are
getting ready for contract renewals are
a lot more likely to renew their
contracts and continue playing the
characters in marvel movies but phase
four is going to look completely
different than from what's come before
so while we might continue to see
Captain America in the movies he might
get used in the same way that Iron Man
is being used in the other vendors films
like there is no Iron Man for that they
have on the books right now but Robert
Downey jr. is all over a bunch of films
so just expect the same treatment for
Captain America in the meantime but that
doesn't mean that they'll never do
another Captain America solo film but
most of you have heard what the Russo
said they said that when Avengers
infinity war picks up he won't be called
Captain America he'll just be like the
Steve Rogers character now I know in the
comics when he got disillusioned with
the government he took the Nomad
identity he wore a different costume I
do think he'll definitely get a costume
upgrade in Avengers infinity war maybe
with a little help from Tony Stark on
the side you know under the radar
because Tony Stark is still working with
the government or maybe from black
panther who has way more money than Tony
Stark but cap is just going to be living
under the radar when he's not with the
Avengers but but obviously they're all
going to meet up again so even if they
hadn't made all these big deals and they
wouldn't have done Civil War they still
would have done the same thing with the
character at the end of the 3rd Captain
America film just because you know who
knew if Chris Evans was going to resign
his contract so they needed to give
something of an end to that character in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe without
completely killing them off so I would
advise you to go back and re-watch the
end of Iron Man 3
then watch Avengers age of Ultron and
they don't address it at all so it is a
little bit funny so you'll probably see
when infinity war picks up when we you
know hit all the beats with all the
different characters like look Oh what
cap has been doing this whole time
he'll just be helping people under the
radar taking down Hydra cells helping
people that need it but also running
from the government they do a really
good job of brushing over plot in the
big Avengers films like filling you in
on backstory that's necessary and moving
things along without getting bogged down
they said that's one of the reasons why
they're not introducing too many
characters in infinity war because they
already have so many that when they
introduce somebody new they have to
include context for that so like that's
why they haven't done Red Hulk yet like
Thunderbolt Ross is totally in the
movies they could totally do Red Hulk in
the future but in order to get that you
have to explain that the government has
their own program on the side in
Thunderbolt Ross is part of that so
don't expect Red Hulk anytime soon but
he's totally fair game in the future
he's just an example like most of their
time is going to be spent working on the
characters they've already introduced
Captain Marvel is one of the few that
they will introduce but they haven't
said whether or not she'll get her
powers I'm assuming she will towards the
end of that film and then when they pick
up in the next Avengers film the fourth
Avengers film it'll be like all-new
all-different Avengers so they'll look
very different you'll have a post
Captain America Avengers he might not
rejoin the team he might just continue
being Steve Rogers but I'm not really
expecting him to call himself nomad but
you can see how Captain Marvel is coming
along so they'll still be a captain in
the Avengers it just won't be Captain
America
it'll be Captain Marvel so yes there
will be more Steve Rogers Chris Evans in
the Marvel Universe but he won't be
calling himself Captain America won't
have the shield won't have the uniform
so let me know do you think that Chris
Evans will resize his marvel contract
and they'll do another solo Captain
America film during phase 4 or do you
think they're going to focus more on
developing new characters and just have
Steve Rogers appear like guest star in
other people's films in the way that
Iron Man is going to guest star in
spider-man homecoming like sometimes you
don't need to give them a solo film you
can just beef up somebody else's film by
sticking them in it so just a quick
reminder that there's a new round of the
Marvel giveaway that's going on right
now all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
the Captain America Civil War DVD is
coming out they'll have a whole bunch of
bonus features they've got all kinds of
deleted scenes so we'll definitely do a
breakdown of that stuff whenever it
drops next week what do you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
my Thor Ragnarok behind the scenes video
and you can click here for my breakdown
of the guardians of the galaxy to see
the favorite leaves thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you